it is so cringeworthy when anyone who
isn't actually funny tries to be funny
it's particularly cringe-worthy when
conservatives try it governor Mike
Huckabee former governor of Arkansas
tries it all the time and it is
generally a spectacular fail this is
what he said on Twitter yesterday he
said quote must have been an awkward
moment for Angela Merkel to sit and to
sit in ceremony as allies as the allies
commemorated d-day that broke the back
of Nazi Germany now yeah this is this is
what he considers funny and I'm saying
that to actually give him the benefit of
the doubt because I genuinely hope it
wasn't an attempt at a genuine analysis
right like it's it's more likely that
this it's this is funny far more than it
is a real real analysis because you know
if we use that logic then Mike Huckabee
it must be extremely painful for you who
was a former governor of a southern
state to sit in anything here in the
United States whether it be the a 4th of
July celebration or whether it be you
know all things considered you're one of
your States your state was one of the
states that try to secede from the union
you know so we definitely broke the back
of the Confederacy so I'm trying to
actually give him some credit and say
that this was his attempt to be funny
because he clearly could not be serious
with this and so obviously you know when
this happens twitter twitter jumps in on
it and and people people actually helped
him to understand how fallacious this
argument was one user on Twitter Michael
Marshall Smith said this he said quote
yeah and the Queen was sitting there
still in a snit about the American War
of Independence
gosh you're stupid and so ignorant of
Europe and so so unfunny so this guy
actually has the same conundrum that I
have
I'm not sure if he was trying to be
funny but I'm just gonna say he was
trying to be funny because he could not
possibly see it be serious but like
Michael pointed out right if you're
trying to be serious Mike Huckabee then
that same logic says that the Queen of
England who is still tied to the same
the same monarchy it's the same monarchy
since the War of Independence so she
would actually this would be more
applicable to her far more than an angle
of Merkel because the Nazi Germany was
thoroughly destroyed furthermore not
only was it destroyed but it's it's
still punished to this day anyone who
who promotes Nazism it's is illegal in
Germany to support anything connected to
the Nazi Party so this is far more
applicable to the Queen of England oh my
goodness do you people even logic I want
to go one step further like I mentioned
with with him being from a southern
state from with him a state that still
rebels in the Confederacy like I mean
I'm in the state of Georgia I drove to
Florida to take my kids for summer break
to their grandparents right and on our
ride to Florida there's two monuments to
the Confederacy that we pass there are
two memorials to the Confederacy that we
pass every single time one of these
times I'm gonna get out and tear one of
them down but I digress the point is is
that whereas in Germany it's illegal to
celebrate the Nazi Party because not
only was it destroyed but they're trying
to destroy it from the hearts of
humanity
George Huckabee George Huckabee anyway
Mike Huckabee I was gonna I was gonna I
was gonna try to be funny but I'm not
Mike Huckabee is still a part of a
collective consciousness in this in this
United States that wants to hold on to
the Confederacy the treasonous
Confederacy for which Lincoln waged
against which Lincoln waged a civil war
to protect and preserve the Union so so
in Germany where it's illegal and where
there are no monuments to Nazism and
it's illegal to
promote Nazism in in in in in in in in
Mike Huckabee's home state of Arkansas
and across the south
we have monuments to the Confederacy so
if anyone has a problem connected to
their history it would be the people who
still celebrate that history still
celebrate the treasonous Confederacy and
still celebrate everything about this
part of American history that almost
destroyed the Union but Mike Huckabee
either in an attempt to be funny
which III don't know I don't know if he
was honestly trying to be funny because
it's painfully unfunny but if he wasn't
trying to be funny it's painfully stupid
it's a painfully stupid analysis god
this is what we're dealing with people
this is this is the level of discourse
this is the level of conservative
intellectualism light like this is one
of the other you choose you tell me in
the comment section do you think this is
an example of of conservative
intellectualism or do you think this was
an example of conservative humor I don't
know which one is worse because they're
both equally stupid and ignorant I'm
sorry I don't want to use mean whereas I
don't let my kids you know I stupid it's
the most asinine thing that I've seen
well just in the last five minutes cuz I
got a cover I got a cover the next story
today's program brought to you in part
by Blink accom slash Pakman blinka
is a great service that I use all the
time what they do is they take thousands
of the most popular non-fiction books
including the newest bestsellers they
condense them into 15-minute audiobooks
that you can listen to and you still get
the most crucial information and
insights from each book and I've
listened to a ton of books on blink Asst
I recently checked out soccer na mcc's
by Simon Cooper we do have after all the
World Cup going on recently we also
been talking about BS jobs and there is
a great new book BS jobs by David
Graeber which I listened to on bling cos
they're constantly adding new books to
the platform you will never run out of
fascinating and critically acclaimed
books to enjoy and our audience can get
a seven day free trial by going to blink
accom slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube I'm putting a link in the video
description and after the free trial if
you like it you can continue enjoying
thousands of condensed audiobooks for
about five bucks a month that's be li NK
is t.com /pa k mas